[triumphant music playing]
[Prue] What about picnicking right here?
Why is Prue dressed as Colonel Sanders?
[Alison] There's a lot
you don't know about Prue.
Not only is she
the thinking man's crumpet,
but she's got a Michelin star
and she's a top scientist.
I have finally achieved
my lifetime's ambition
of cloning a dinosaur with human DNA.
Wow. Whose DNA did you use?
[loud thud]
[thudding]
[suspenseful music playing]
[loud snarl]
-Oh, no! He's escaped.
-Who?
Tyranno-Paul-us rex.
[eerie music playing]
[growling loudly]
You were so preoccupied
with whether you should,
you never stopped to worry
about whether you could.
I think it's the other way round, babes.
[screams] Oh, my God,
look at the size of it!
Come on, let's go!
[engine whirring]
I can't believe it.
His eyes are so blue.
-[tense music playing]
-[grunting]
[growling loudly]
Why is he so angry?
[continues growling]
His little arms are too short.
He can't do his Hollywood handshake.
[roars loudly]
I'll sort this out.
-Be careful.
-I will.
-Come on, big fella.
-[Alison whimpering]
Give me the handshake.
Hand me one of those cold reptilian claws.
[growling]
[screaming]
[screams]
Oh, my God!
-Prue, floor it.
-But what about Noel?
Don't worry. I'll phone Dermot.
[tyres screeching]
[tense music playing]
[snarls]
[brakes squealing]
Right, guys, ready to do the sketch?
You've just done it. You've eaten Noel.
It wasn't me.
[gasps] But if it wasn't you…
who was it?
[growling loudly]
[in high-pitched Northern accent]
Welcome to The Great British Baking Show.
[roaring]
Turned out nice again.
[birds chirping]
I can see the tent. It's so there,
but it doesn't feel real just yet.
If my grandma could see me now,
I think she'd be super proud.
I'm going to the tent! I'm here! [laughs]
-I'm absolutely…
-[bleats]
…myself.
[Alison] From across Britain,
thousands applied.
Just 12 of the country's best home bakers
have made it to the Baking Show tent.
-Oh, my goodness.
-Wow. Look.
I feel very honoured
to be the first Ukrainian here.
Exciting!
[Alison] But this year's competition…
This is Ready Steady Cook, isn't it?
-[all laughing]
-…is like no other.
There's a little twisteroonie.
[Alison] Paul and Prue
have set challenges…
-What the hell am I doing here?
-…that have to be seen…
This doesn't look like baking to me.
This is science.
-…to be believed.
-[Prue] That is really difficult.
-It's great, isn't it?
-[laughs]
I think Paul Hollywood's a bit of a daddy,
bit of a hunky man.
Will I blush? Yeah.
Everyone's scared about Paul,
but Prue's low-key savage.
[clears throat]
[Alison laughing]
-[Noel] Each week those who rise…
-Well done.
…will be crowned Star Baker.
-Oh, God, it's gorgeous.
-[Noel] Those who crumble…
Looks like
it's been dropped out of a tree.
…will have to leave the tent.
I knew the pressure in here would be real.
Quick, quick, quick!
-Steaming up.
-And it's real.
-[Alison] But who…
-[Pui Man] Oh!
-Look disgusting.
-[laughs]
…will go on to win…
How far do you think
you could go in this competition?
…The Great British Baking Show?
-Maybe tomorrow?
-[laughs]
Just wondering how I'm gonna cut this.
-Swizzle it round.
-Sorry?
I don't know if that's a word. Swivel.
Have you just told me to swivel?
[all laughing]
[opening theme music playing]
[Alison] It's Cake Week,
and after three challenges,
one of our crop of new bakers
will be named Star Baker,
while one will have to leave the tent.
[all laughing]
[Alison] Welcome, bakers, to the tent.
I know you're all a little bit nervous.
-I mean, I'm a little bit nervous.
-Are you?
-I still get starstruck in front of Paul.
-[chuckles]
It's his eyes, they're like sapphires
in a naan bread.
[laughter]
So, for your first-ever challenge,
the judges would like you
to make a Swiss roll.
Your Swiss roll
must be beautifully decorated.
And your sponge must have an inlay design
and be rolled with at least
two different fillings,
creating the perfect swirl.
-I rolled him earlier.
-[all chuckle]
You have two hours.
-[Noel] Okay. You ready?
-I'm ready. I'm born ready.
[exhales] Strap in. On your marks.
-Get set.
-[in sing-song voice] Bake.
Hey.
Er… [chuckles] slightly overwhelmed.
Feel all right.
Maybe I should feel more nervous.
Maybe it's a false sense
of security. [laughs]
[Lesley] Absolutely amazing
to actually be in the tent.
It's fantastic. I'm enjoying myself.
I'm very nervous.
Still quite shaky, to be honest.
Oh.
The perfect Swiss roll
is very hard to achieve.
It should be round, not oval.
And then, of course,
we want the perfect swirl.
[Iain] Whoo.
A Swiss roll sponge
is quite malleable actually.
Beautifully soft.
You don't want it to crack,
and what we're asking for
is an inlay into that sponge.
This is the decorative batter.
So it's just equal parts icing sugar,
flour, butter, egg white.
Basically, you draw all over
a piece of paper,
and on top of that, the sponge goes,
so when it bakes,
the inlay remains in the sponge.
[Prue] It's important
that the colour's vibrant
because we must be able to see it.
We want something bold,
full of colour and full of flavour.
[Prue] Of course I want it to taste
absolutely delicious,
but I want it to be surprising too.
People saying,
"Gosh, this is their first week
and look what they've done."
-[Paul] Morning, Iain.
-How are you guys doing?
-Good. Thank you.
-Yeah.
Right. Tell us all about your Swiss roll.
My Swiss roll is based
on Queen's University in Belfast.
It's where I started baking.
So at the end of my last exam,
instead of going out partying,
I baked my first loaf of bread.
-[all chuckling]
-As you do.
[Noel] After graduating eight years ago,
Iain and his girlfriend, Dervla,
settled in Belfast.
A software engineer
with an artistic streak,
Iain relaxes creating
unique bread-based masterpieces.
[Iain] The Paul Holly-bread.
[Noel] His ambitious
Belfast University inlay design
will be baked into a sheet
of chiffon sponge
filled with flavours
from a childhood favourite.
A Northern Irish Fifteen.
It's like a wee tray bake.
Fifteen digestives,
15 cherries, 15 marshmallows.
And you just whack
a tin of condensed milk on it.
I'm really nervous
this is going to be too sweet.
-It's not gonna be too sweet. No.
-Okay. Well, I'll find out.
[Alison] While Iain celebrates
his student days…
Fifteens? Oh, my gosh, I love Fifteens.
-[both chuckling]
-I'm so excited.
[Pui Man sighs]
…Pui Man's reliving
the taste of her teens.
[Pui Man] In Hong Kong,
I drink lemon tea every day,
so I'm making lemon curd
matcha cream Swiss roll.
[Alison] Bridal designer Pui Man
lives in Essex
with her husband and two children.
Hello, everyone.
[Alison] When she's not stitching
stunning wedding dresses,
she bakes beautiful cakes
for the local community.
Look at that.
[Alison] She's hoping her combination
of matcha and lemon works,
as taste-testing her creation
has been tricky.
-I never really eat sweets.
-You don't eat sweets.
-I don't eat sweets.
-[Noel] Biscuits?
-No. I bake them, but I don't eat them.
-Do you taste them?
-I taste them, but I don't--
-And then you spit it out?
[both laughing]
Like tasting wine. [laughs]
-[both laughing]
-These are nice.
Lemons are on the menu for Leighton too.
I'm gonna take you to the Amalfi Coast.
Last year, Eric and I were in Italy,
and we loved the lemon groves,
so I'm recreating that
in a Swiss roll today.
[Noel] Originally from South Wales,
software delivery manager Leighton
now lives in Surrey with husband, Eric,
and their Irish terrier.
-Cilla, do you like Welsh cake?
-[Eric chuckles]
[Noel] Packed full of zesty lemon curd
and Chantilly cream,
Leighton's Swiss roll features
a colourful lemon tree design.
But there might be a problem
with his inlay batter.
-There's a lot of bits and pieces.
-The butter was a bit cold this morning.
[Alison] Well, we'll just mix that
in the bowl.
[Leighton] You know what?
I mean, once I pipe it, it'll be fine.
[chuckles]
[Tom] Okay, pipe that pattern.
[Alison] Prue and Paul
will be expecting striking inlays
that stand out from the crowd.
[Iain] The black is gonna be
the outline for the university building,
the red, brick.
Wherever the yellow is, the grout?
[Noel] And while Iain makes a start
on his intricate architecture…
[Aaron] Oh, it's making my eyes
go cross-eyed. [laughs]
…Aaron's taking on one of nature's
most impressive feats of engineering.
This is a beehive design
because my sister loves bees.
[Alison] A computer systems architect,
Aaron and his sister, Jarusha,
live in London,
where they still enjoy
making a mess in the kitchen.
The earliest memory I had of you baking…
[Aaron] The bread roll?
You put it in the bin
and the bin set on fire.
[both laugh]
[Alison] Aaron will roll lemon curd cream
and blueberry and elderflower jam
inside his highly decorated sponge.
The thing that takes the longest
is the inlay design.
At home, I managed to do it once, but…
[laughing] You look so shocked.
It was once, but I still managed to do it.
[Noel] Hassan's channelling
positivity too.
[Hassan] My decorative design
is blue roses.
I remember hearing blue roses
means achieving the impossible.
[Noel] Hailing from South Yorkshire,
yoga-loving Hassan
is an analytical scientist,
and likes nothing more than to let loose
after a hard day in the lab.
-[axe clattering]
-Oh my days.
[Noel] His decadent bake will see him
roll chocolate sponge
around thick caramel
and a milk chocolate and coffee ganache.
-[in sing-song voice] Hello.
-Hello.
[Noel] How far do you think
you could go in this competition?
You could get through today, right?
-Maybe tomorrow?
-[laughs]
Who do you think is good in here?
-Everyone, actually.
-Everyone's good.
-What, even him?
-[Hassan] Yeah.
-What about her? No way.
-No, she's really good.
[Noel] She's good as well.
What about Prue?
Prue's got a Michelin star.
I've never seen a Michelin star.
Is it to do with the Michelin Man?
-Yeah, 'cause it…
-That guy made of tyres?
I think they just get someone
to dress up as him and hand it out.
[laughs]
-Paul. Paul's the right shape.
-Oh, Paul.
[Noel] Paul's the Michelin Man.
That was the best-kept secret,
and you've just ruined it.
[both laugh]
[Alison] While the bakers
put the finishing touches
to their inlay designs…
[Iain] We're putting the sky on.
[Leighton] Does this whisk you back
to the Amalfi Coast?
…then freeze them to firm them up
before baking…
[sighs] Okay.
Oosh. Right, in there.
[Noel] …attention turns to sponge.
[Nataliia] Nice and soft.
[Noel] Its fluffy, cloud-like crumb
relies on whisking air
into eggs and sugar…
It's perfect. Right, in we go.
…before folding in flour,
taking care not to beat out
all the important bubbles.
Nice and gently.
[Tom] It's a bit green, isn't it?
'Cause everyone loves
brightly coloured green foods.
[Alison] Creative entrepreneur Tom
and his partner, George, live in London.
How much cream?
Growing up, Tom learned to bake
at the knee
of his Danish grandmother, Toni.
-[Toni] Put a lot of butter on.
-[Tom] This is my kind of baking.
[Noel] Tom's Swiss roll will contain
a swirl of blueberry compote
and mascarpone cream,
while his bright green sponge
will be adorned in his family tartan.
I don't want to put any pressure on Tom,
but I am 16% Scottish.
Sixteen percent?
That actually might be more than me.
It's in her foot.
[all laughing]
Sponge is done. Okay, I'm gonna get
my pattern out of the freezer.
[Noel] With their inlays frozen solid…
Sponge is going in.
…the bakers must spread their batter
carefully over the top.
[Nataliia in sing-song voice] Like that.
[Leighton] I haven't sifted in
the flour. Panic.
Oh, I've never forgotten the flour before.
I'll do what I can
without scraping the design off.
[Alison] And Leighton's not the only one
struggling with his sponge.
I'm not completely happy.
It was a little bit lumpy,
so I've had to knock a bit more air
out of it than I would like to.
[Alison] A fitness fanatic
with a blue belt in Brazilian jiu-jitsu,
Toby works
for a health and fitness start-up
and lives in Warwickshire
with his girlfriend, Syd,
and their Border Collie Lab, Bexley.
Inspired by his mum's
rhubarb crumble and custard,
he'll fill his Swiss roll with rhubarb jam
and elderflower-infused creme diplomat.
If someone came in here now
and attacked us,
could you save my life?
Maybe.
Like, if Noel came and attacked you,
could you, like, take him out?
I'd feel confident if it was Noel.
-You could take Noel out, no problem…
-Take me out to dinner?
…with a few jiu-jitsu moves.
You can't kill someone who's already dead.
[all laughing]
-[Paul] Jessika, good morning.
-Hello, Jessika.
-[Alison] Hi, Jessika.
-Hi.
-[Alison] Oh, wow. That's so good.
-[Prue] That is exquisite.
I drew my own hand.
It's representing my sister.
She's my favourite person.
[Alison] Jessika and sister, Lucy,
grew up baking together.
[Jessika] Am I gonna put in
all the elbow work?
[Alison] Jessika lives in London.
A service designer by day,
she's a drag king by night…
[sultry music playing]
…performing as her alter ego,
Oliver Clothezoff.
She'll fill her coconut sponge
with a swirl of zingy grapefruit curd
and a white chocolate
and black pepper ganache.
-[Paul] Oh, yes, please.
-Ooh.
-That sounds amazing.
-Doesn't that sound good?
You've ticked all the boxes
for flavours and design.
-Now it's all down to the bake.
-Don't.
[suspenseful music playing]
[tray slamming]
Pui Man, what are you doing?
Banging the bubbles out.
It's obvious, Paul.
-Banging the bubbles out.
-[slamming continues]
Bakers, you are halfway through.
You've got one hour left.
Good Lord.
Which is exactly how long I lasted
on a juice retreat.
[laughter]
In the oven we go.
-Time is on.
-[Lesley] Twelve minutes.
We're in. We're stressed.
[Alison] As the first
of the Swiss roll sponges begin baking…
-[exclaims]
-…Leighton's playing catch-up.
[Leighton] I added the flour.
Hopefully I haven't knocked out
too much air.
Purely nerves of the tent.
[Noel] And those nerves
are about to go up a notch.
Jam's on. Next, I'm gonna do my creme pat.
[Noel] There's still fillings to do.
There's a lot of stuff happening.
So I've got my cherry jam,
my coconut digestives,
and then I still have to make
my marshmallow cream.
[Alison] Not only must they be
full of flavour…
Oh, lemon curd is so unctuous.
…but work in perfect harmony.
[Jessika] I'm just cracking pepper down
for the white chocolate whipped ganache.
The warmth really complements
the grapefruit curd.
It's mango, passionfruit… jam.
-We can smell it. It's lovely.
-Wow. That's smells amazing.
-Thank you.
-[Prue] Smells delicious.
Hope so… you guys like it.
[Noel] Born and raised in Ukraine,
Nataliia left four years ago
before war broke out,
followed shortly after by her parents.
They now live in Yorkshire, where,
along with Nataliia's husband, Harry,
and their three-year-old daughter,
Francesca,
they remember home
with a traditional Ukrainian family feast.
[Harry] That's not Ukrainian.
That's a Yorkshire pudding.
[Alison] Her vibrant inlay is inspired
by the wildflowers of her homeland,
while the tropical flavours
are Harry's favourite.
Is your husband glad you're on this?
Yeah, he is so proud of me.
-[Noel] Can he bake as well?
-No. [chuckles]
-What is he good at?
-I don't know. He is--
"I don't know." What's he good at?
"I don't know.
I don't know why I married him."
[both laughing]
-I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
-He's watching. You can't say that.
I'm sorry, my love.
[Jasmine] This is lemon curd.
My great-aunt would always make
this amazing lemon roulade,
so this is my take
on her lemon Swiss roll.
[Noel] Although she now lives in London,
it's Scotland
medical student Jasmine calls home,
and is happiest beating a path
beside her local loch.
I'll race you.
[all laughing]
[Noel] As well as lemon curd,
she'll add lemon zest
to both her sponge and mascarpone cream.
But her fresh flavours
face stiff competition.
[Jasmine] There's a lot of people
using lemons here.
[Lesley] I'm just making my lemon curd.
Ooh, steaming up.
[Alison] Lesley lives in Kent
and has worked as a hairdresser
for the last 45 years,
serving up curls and cake
to her loyal customers.
But granddaughter Mabel's her biggest fan.
-[Mabel] Big one.
-[Lesley] It is a big one.
[Alison] Lesley's lemon and blueberry
Swiss roll
features a white daisy inlay design,
Mabel's favourite flower.
She's my heartbeat. She really is.
I can't wait to teach her baking.
I want her to be able to do
a curly blow dry
and bake a batch of cookies
by the time she's five.
[Noel] A Baking Show first,
this year's batch of bakers
includes one more cake-making coiffeur.
-There are two hairdressers in this tent.
-Yeah.
We're sorted, aren't we?
We're gonna get our hair done.
-Curly blows all round.
-[laughter]
[Noel] Nadia lives in Liverpool
with her partner Daniel
and her two daughters.
Nadia, we're making fresh brioche.
[Alison] Inspired by
Italian father Francesco, a chef,
she's passing on the love of food
to Maria and Rosa-Bella.
-Put a bit of muscle into it.
-[giggles]
[Noel] Nadia's Swiss roll
is full of cherry and almond flavour
with a generous glug of cherry liqueur
in her jam
and almond essence in her sponge.
[Nadia] Can really smell all that almond.
I'm actually gonna bring it out now.
[Alison] Because a Swiss roll sponge
is so thin…
Let's see.
…the time between under- and overbaked
is a matter of moments.
It can go one way or the other
very, very quickly.
-[Noel] Get it out too soon…
-[Nadia] Yeah.
…and they could be serving a claggy cake.
One more minute.
-But a minute over…
-[Toby] It's not quite there.
…and their sponge could crack when rolled.
I'm happy! [laughs]
[Alison] But perfectly baked sponge
won't matter…
Oh! Sorry.
…if their inlay designs haven't survived.
[Tom] Honestly,
this part is totally terrifying.
[Pui Man] Peel off. Come on.
[Iain] Oh, it's getting tight.
Those are my lemons. Superb.
[Aaron] Oh, thank God.
That's beautiful. Well done.
That is epic.
[exhales]
Now I just need to get it rolled.
[Jasmine] I'm gonna roll it
to get the swirl into it
while it's a little bit warm.
[Aaron] Gonna put that in the fridge.
-[Noel] While their sponges cool…
-Carry on the lemon curd.
…there's a scramble to finish fillings…
This is my ganache,
and then I can work on my caramel.
…and start decorations.
Do my chocolate.
The marshmallow cream
is gonna be right up to the wire.
[Alison] It's crucial every curd,
jam and ganache is cool
before the bakers begin assembly.
Quick, quick, quick!
[Alison] If either their sponge
or fillings are still warm,
they risk serving Paul and Prue
a Swiss roll without its signature swirl.
I mean, how stressful
can making a cake be?
Er, what do I do? [sighs]
[Noel] Toby's about to find out.
I need to make my creme pat again.
It's a little bit lumpy.
[Noel] And so is Hassan.
My caramel seems to have gone bad.
I'll have to do it again.
Not ideal.
Bakers, you have 15 minutes left.
-Oh, no.
-It's exciting, innit?
Take two on the creme pat.
I knew the pressure in here would be real.
And it's real.
[Alison] As Toby and Hassan race
to finish their fillings…
[Hassan] This caramel looks much better.
I just need it to cool down,
get it chilling for as long as possible.
It takes a while.
[Noel] …the rest of the bakers
are starting to assemble.
Ah, no. We've got a slight crack.
[Nadia] Oh, dear.
I don't think I baked it for long enough.
Oh.
Jam go in, baby. Perfect texture.
[Iain] Does this look like jam to you?
-Crunchy jam.
-[both laugh]
[Jessika] Whipped ganache.
Matcha cream. What else?
[Nadia] Lots of cherries.
[Pui Man] Hope it's good.
Bakers, you have five minutes left.
-[Toby] Oh, my God.
-You all right?
To the wire. Creme pat's still hot,
but we are where we are.
[Alison] Hassan's feeling the heat too.
My caramel's still a little bit too warm.
It's risky business.
Right, I'm starting to roll it.
Like a sushi maker. [laughs]
[Tom] Nervy times.
Oh, God.
[Nadia] Oh no, it's split.
Oh!
[Lesley] It's not the prettiest.
I'm very happy with that.
It looks like a Swiss roll.
[Noel] While the rest of the bakers
begin decorating,
Toby and Hassan…
[Hassan] I'm just gonna
put my fillings in.
…are out of cooling time.
[Hassan] The caramel's still quite soft.
I mean, it looks good,
but it's gonna be a horrible mess.
Bakers, this is your one-minute call.
[Hassan] I've gotta roll it up.
Ah, this is gonna go everywhere.
I'm gonna pipe buttercream daisies.
[Aaron] This is chocolate honeycomb.
I made Ukrainian flowers. Beautiful.
Mm. It's a Swiss roll. It's got no cracks.
[Hassan] Ah. It's got no stability!
Flaked almonds hide a multitude of sins.
Done.
[Hassan] I've had a mare.
I've had a right mare.
Bakers, your time is up.
[sighs]
[Noel] Please step away
from your Swiss rolls.
[exhales]
-That's your first bake done!
-[Noel] Whoo!
-[Alison] Yes!
-Oh, my God.
-[all clapping]
-[Lesley] Look at that.
-I'm in shock.
-That's crazy.
I've proper… I've proper mucked it.
Yeah. Ain't no swirl there.
[gentle music playing]
[Alison] For the very first time,
the bakers will now face the judgement
of Paul and Prue.
-Hi, Tom.
-How are you doing?
[suspenseful music playing]
[Prue] I think you've done an amazing job.
It's the right shape.
It's amazingly dramatic to look at.
-[Paul] Fascinating colour, yeah?
-[both laugh]
[Prue] Tartan is really neatly done.
-[Paul] Let's have a look at this.
-It's got a good swirl.
I think it's delicious. Very light.
The sponge is light, the filling is light.
It's unique. I've never seen
anything quite like that before.
-Lovely.
-Well done.
-Thank you so much.
-That was good.
Yeah, it was nice.
[gentle music playing]
It does look good. I like the colour.
I love the pizza on the side.
-[Jasmine] It's only lemons.
-[laughter]
It does, yeah. Right.
I'll give you a big slice, Prue.
[Noel] That's a good swirl.
-[Prue] Very good lemon.
-[Jasmine] Thank you.
Flavour-wise, it's nice and tart,
but you've just gone over on the bake.
[gentle music playing]
Happy with it?
-Mm… no?
-[laughter]
[Paul] Not really much of a swirl.
[Lesley] I think I had a little bit
too much filling in there.
-Flavour's beautiful.
-[Lesley] Is it?
Nice balance between the lemon curd
and blueberry.
[Paul] And the sponge
is baked beautifully well.
Your issue is the swirl itself.
[whimsical music playing]
-[Paul] Love the decoration.
-But you covered two-thirds of it.
Can you lift it off?
-I think that's much more impressive.
-Okay.
[Prue] I love that. Beautiful flavour.
Mm. Think you've done a great job.
Design's great, sponge is well-baked,
and a great balance of flavours.
-Well done.
-Cheers. Thank you very much.
-How dare they strip your cake down?
-[Aaron laughs]
They took its pants off.
[cheerful music playing]
-I think you've had issues.
-Yeah.
That's covering up a multitude of sins.
I took it out three minutes early.
That's what my problem was.
-Then it broke.
-[Paul] See what it tastes like.
-[Prue] Did you put almond essence in?
-[Nadia] A little bit.
-I think there's a bit too much.
-I agree. It's a little bit heavy.
But the cherries needed more of a punch
to balance out the almond.
-They're a little bit too sweet.
-Okay.
[gentle music playing]
[Paul] I like the decoration.
If Prue was a Swiss roll,
it'd be that one.
[laughter]
-[Prue] I think it's delicious.
-[gasps]
I just think there's too much filling.
[Paul] Too much of the matcha cream
and not enough curd.
-The overall texture is very good.
-Thank you.
[Paul] But the balance of it
is not quite right.
[gentle music playing]
Your sponge has gone very much oval
-rather than round.
-Flat.
Yeah, I think I knocked
too much air out of it.
[Paul] Yeah. Okay.
Let's have a quick look at this.
-Was this warm when you put it all in?
-It was to the wire, yeah.
[Paul] Yeah, you can see
it's all disappeared.
[Prue] It tastes like rhubarb and custard.
I love it.
[Toby laughs] Good.
[Paul] The flavour's lovely.
I think the texture is wrong.
-It's a bit chewy.
-Yeah.
[suspenseful music playing]
It is really artistic and interesting,
but it doesn't show up
as much as I'd hoped it would.
I actually really like the flavour,
but the curd has not been done well.
Needs to be much thicker.
The flavour's great. It's the texture.
Yeah.
[suspenseful music playing]
[Prue] What I think is so lovely
is it absolutely looks
as if it's embroidered.
-[Nataliia] Thank you so much.
-[Prue] It's beautiful, I love that.
[Nataliia] Ah!
-It's delicious to eat.
-[Nataliia] Yeah?
-However…
-However. [chuckles]
-You've overbaked the sponge.
-Okay.
But flavour-wise, stunning. Thank you.
Okay, thank you so much.
-[Noel whispering] Well done.
-Ah! [laughs]
[whimsical music playing]
[Prue] I love your design.
Those colours are just wonderful.
It's a bit tough, isn't it?
-Oh, there you go.
-[Prue laughs]
I think that's because
my cold butter this morning.
[Paul] It is the butter.
It's almost created a skin.
The sponge itself,
I find a little bit claggy.
I think it could come down
to your folding.
[Prue] Folding the flour in.
Yeah. The flavours, though, are very good.
[gentle music playing]
[Prue] So, Hassan, not your best morning.
-[Paul] No.
-[Hassan] Quite disappointed myself.
[Paul] It looks like a roulade
rather than a Swiss roll.
[Paul] Wow.
If I had a ball of ice cream
next to this in a bowl,
-I would be totally happy.
-[Paul] Yeah, absolutely.
Flavour-wise, stunning,
absolutely delicious,
but looks like
it's been dropped out of a tree.
[chuckles]
[Hassan] Okay, cheers.
They did say "stunning and delicious".
Yeah, but "looked like
it fell out of a tree".
[Noel chuckles]
[gentle music playing]
That is one
mighty impressive-looking Swiss roll.
Thank you.
It's a shame it sat down on itself.
It's a wee bit of an oval, yeah.
-[Paul] But that design is…
-[Prue] Extremely impressive.
[Noel] It's amazing.
-Mm. The flavours are stunning.
-Thank you.
[Prue] I was nervous that the marshmallow
and the jam would make it all too sweet,
but it's delicious.
-You left the condensed milk out.
-[Iain] I did.
It's such a student thing.
I'm 29. I'm not a student any more.
[laughter]
[Noel] You look 15.
Thank you.
[laughter]
[Iain] I thought
I was taking a bit of a risk.
I couldn't have possibly imagined
that it would turn out as good as it did.
First one in the bag, no major mess-ups,
but definitely not getting ahead of myself
and thinking, "Oh, it went great",
'cause I practised that one a lot.
They all… loved the… design and flavours.
I'm so happy.
It was a little bit firm.
It's the first time that's happened.
It's the curse of the tent.
Like Prue said, I think, not my best day.
[Toby] I'm lagging behind,
so praying that the Technical
is something that I have made before.
Just get on with it.
That's what my husband said.
"Just get on with it." [laughs]
[gentle music playing]
[Alison] Each week, the bakers
face a mystery second challenge
shrouded beneath gingham.
Hello, bakers. Welcome back to the tent.
It's time for your Technical challenge
set for you by Captain Cakeman himself,
Paul Hollywood.
Paul, have you got any words of wisdom
for our beautiful bakers?
First of all, don't panic.
Use your baking intuition.
It is gonna be difficult,
but it's not impossible.
Comforting that it's not impossible.
Almost impossible, but not impossible.
So, as always,
this challenge is judged blind.
So, Paul, Prue,
you may now leave the tent.
Thank you so much.
-[Noel] You know what they're gonna do?
-What?
-Thumb wars.
-Smart money's on Prue.
She's got big thumbs.
They're like turkey drumsticks.
[laughter]
[Alison] The judges would like you to bake
nine perfectly decorated fondant fancies.
The judges are looking for light sponge,
well-set jam, smooth buttercream,
and precise fondant decoration.
You have two hours and 15 minutes.
Sounds easy, right?
Does sound easy,
but there's a little twisteroonie.
You'll need to figure out the flavours
and the recipe all by yourselves,
using only some of the ingredients
in front of you.
There's a perfect example
of a fondant fancy
underneath your gingham cloth.
You have five minutes.
Get your detective hats on,
'cause your five minutes start now.
[tense music playing]
[Nadia groans]
I've never made one of these before.
First time for everything.
Jasmine did say,
literally as we went to the loo earlier…
"There's one thing that I really, really
hope it's not: a fondant fancy." [gasps]
Just trying to work out the flavours.
I think it's cherry.
You want to go for cherry,
but it really tastes like raspberry.
There's definitely almond notes to it.
I'm not sure. [laughs]
I'm just gonna eat the whole thing
and hope for the best.
[Prue] So, Paul, fondant fancies.
This'll be challenging for our bakers.
We've obviously taken the recipe away,
but left them with all the ingredients
and a few more on top of that.
But essentially, what is in this
is raspberry and almond.
By "almond", I don't mean ground almonds.
I mean almond extract,
which is where the flavour will come from.
But we've given them
ground almonds as well.
We've given them everything.
We've given them a perfect example.
So they should understand
what type of sponge it is.
Once they have the sponge ready,
they've got to prepare the buttercream.
Again, has almond extract in there.
Also, it's got the jam, raspberry jam,
and raspberry flavouring
in the fondant's icing.
-That is delicious.
-It is.
[Prue] Their first time in the tent,
and we've given them
a really difficult Technical challenge.
It's great, isn't it?
[both laughing]
[Alison] Bakers, your five minutes is up.
[exhales]
You ready? On your marks.
-Get set.
-Taste and bake.
Oh, my God.
[Noel] The bakers must now
hand back their fondant fancies…
I should've ate all of it.
I don't know what I'm doing.
…and have just two and a quarter hours
to complete the challenge.
I'm just gonna start.
What the hell am I doing here?
Line my tin, make my sponge.
When I was younger,
I would make microwave cakes with my mum.
Just equal parts everything,
and it's foolproof sponge.
Fingers crossed it is foolproof today.
They've given us lots of ingredients,
so I have to work out whether
there's ground almonds in the sponge.
I don't think there is.
[Alison] The flavour in Paul's sponge
comes entirely from almond extract.
Ooh, that's potent.
[Alison] The addition of ground almonds
will produce
a dense sponge lacking in rise.
I risked it and I put the ground almond
in the mixture.
One tablespoon.
Thirty grams of ground almonds.
It's a bit curdled,
but, ah, it'll be all right.
Chuck it all in. Why not?
-[Leighton] Let's see.
-You're going fast. Watch yourself!
-I know.
-Go faster!
-Come on.
-Whoo!
Little bit… Let's see.
[Noel] You ride by the seat of your pants.
-I haven't got a clue what I'm doing.
-You're a jazz baker.
[Nataliia] I'm happy with the consistency.
[Tom] Oh, this is very dry.
This is like bread dough.
Try and get my sponge in
as soon as possible
to give it time to cool.
Seems like cake. We're going in.
[Nataliia] Hope it will be good.
Sleep tight.
Set the timer!
I think 15 minutes.
One-eighty. Regular baking temperature.
One-seventy, until I think it's right.
I'm gonna go for 15 minutes,
and then I'm gonna check.
Now I'm gonna make the jam.
They've given us the options.
Cherry, raspberry or strawberry jam.
I've got a feeling it was raspberry.
I think it's raspberries. I have no idea.
So I've just chucked them in.
-Jessika, how are you doing?
-I think I'm okay.
-My sponge is in.
-You think?
Do you think your drag king
would be coping better
with what's going on?
Oliver Clothezoff has way more confidence
than I do.
-Really?
-Yes.
How would he be dealing with this then?
With a lot of swagger,
with a lot of holding the crotch area.
-Really?
-Yeah, it's a bit explicit.
[Nadia] Sieving my jam.
Looks great, and it's smooth,
so that's a small win.
[Nataliia] So I'll check my sponge.
It's a little sticky. Needs a bit more.
[Tom] The sponge,
not rising in the centre.
I've also brought it down to 170,
'cause we're getting a lot of browning.
-Bakers, you are halfway through!
-How much?
Next I'm gonna make my buttercream.
[Noel] Like the sponge,
Paul's buttercream is flavoured
with just a hint of almond extract.
-That's good.
-Okay. Love that.
So I put in a wee taste of honey.
I think that might have been the flavour,
but I have no idea.
-My cake'd be due out.
-It's close.
It's coming out.
Still liquid. Interesting.
[Toby] Seems good.
It's risen really nicely in the middle.
Yeah, we're sitting at about half
of what it's meant to be. [laughs]
I'm concerned about the middle here.
It's a wee bit soft.
Iain, we can't have nerves in the tent.
-What we gonna do?
-I mean--
-We could meditate.
-I'd love a wee meditation.
Close your eyes
and take yourself to a beach.
-Okay.
-Blocking out all the noise around you.
-Ommm!
-[hums]
The waves are crashing.
They're taking me out to sea.
-Don't speak. Just hum.
-[laughs]
I'm just upping the temp
'cause I need it to be cooked now.
-How long have we got?
-Bakers, you have half an hour left.
How do you know?
You've got no watch. Nor have I.
[both laughing]
Whole thing's a lie.
Oh, no!
My cake has collapsed in the middle.
We've had a mare.
Hopefully, though, they just don't eat
the central one. I'll hide it.
I'm starting my fondant icing.
I'm gonna make it
the way I normally make it at home.
Just gonna do the sugar with some water.
No idea.
Er, what else?
[Alison] Paul's fondant icing
contains raspberry extract…
You know what?
I'm gonna add a little bit of cherry.
I think it's rose water.
That was a lot of cherry.
…and should be coloured a deep pink.
[Tom] Going kind of heavy.
[Hassan] I've added too much water.
It's like a pastelly pink.
-That looks good.
-Did you put your finger on my sponge?
-No. [laughs]
-You almost put your finger on my sponge.
Almost. Look, my hands are clean.
[Tom] It almost looks like a flapjack.
Trim the edges, then measure it,
and then nine equal bits.
[Lesley] Very exact.
My degree was maths. I still can't add up.
[Nadia] It looks a bit on the brown side.
That looks like the back of Paul's hand.
When he's judging,
imagine him getting his fake tan put on
-with a fireman's hose.
-No, 'cause I'll just laugh.
-I am actually gonna do that.
-In his skimpy briefs. His goggles on.
-I won't be able to keep a straight face.
-And me like that.
-I'm gonna have to tell him what you said.
-[laughs]
I can't serve it. This is raw.
So no one's getting that one.
We're doing eight fondant fancies.
Now we'll fill these all with jam.
[Pui Man] Jam in the hole.
I'm Franken-caking them
to make them roughly about the same height
to compensate for my shoddy cutting.
I am gonna put the lids back on.
I've rather overfilled that one.
We'll hide that in the middle.
Bakers, you have ten minutes.
-I'm just adding my buttercream on top.
-Nine little blobs.
[Hassan] My buttercream
is slightly too soft.
[Aaron] I'm hoping
the icing covers a multitude of sins.
Maybe it will, maybe it won't.
-I'm scared.
-Here goes.
[Nataliia] Over the top.
[Tom] Oh, they're really taking
a lot of icing.
Should have crumb-coated with buttercream.
Didn't think.
They're like little fairy cakes,
aren't they?
-They look disgusting.
-[laughs]
[Tom] Bit messy.
[laughs] I'm so sorry.
[Jasmine] This is a hot pink mess.
Bakers, you have one minute left.
[Toby] I really love taking it
right to the wire.
[Tom] Oh, my God. These are hideous.
[Hassan] They've kind of blended together.
I don't think they look that bad. [laughs]
[Toby] The final fancy.
[Jessika in sing-song voice]
Do not drop them.
Oh! What shall I do?
I'm gonna put the worst one at the back.
Bakers, your time is up.
Well done.
-[exhales]
-[Leighton] I love them.
In fact,
I might bake another nine tonight.
Please bring up your fondant fancies
and place them behind your photos.
Oh, my God.
Mine is stuck with icing to the table.
-Oh, my gosh, Toby.
-[Jessika] Well done.
[Jasmine] They look so good.
[Tom] Wow. What a fancy table.
[Noel] It's judgement time
for the bakers' first Technical challenge.
Okay, so what we're looking for
are nine beautifully formed
fondant fancies.
Almond buttercream with an almond sponge
with a raspberry fondant on the outside.
Raspberry jam in the middle as well.
You had a lot of red herrings.
Ground almonds definitely not inside
because you'll not get the height,
but we'll test them
and see what they're gonna taste like.
These are pretty small, Prue.
-I'm guessing ground almonds.
-[Prue] Yes.
[Paul] Be interesting
to see what's inside.
They've managed to get some jam in there.
-[Prue] I don't think that's bad.
-[Paul] Just very small.
-[Prue] Beautifully high.
-[Paul] The height on these are good.
Can't believe
we're gonna have 12 of these.
[laughter]
I do think there's ground almonds in there
but the colour's not bad.
-Now, these are…
-[Prue] Pretty messy.
[Paul] But they're all messy,
so there is consistency.
-[laughter]
-[Paul] But the colour's the right tone.
It is quite dense sponge.
Moving on to our pink fancies.
It's not the colour we wanted.
[Prue] They're quite neat.
There's a very strange flavour in there.
Is it rose?
-What the--
-[laughter]
That's way off base.
-I like the colour of these.
-[Prue] The height is very good.
[Paul] The decoration is neat.
They're all the same.
-There's ground almonds in there.
-[Prue] It's quite nice cake.
-[Paul] Moving on.
-[Prue] This is abstract decoration.
The colour's good.
-[Paul] Ground almonds again.
-[Prue] It's raspberry jam.
[Paul] Has someone cut their finger?
I mean, that is way, way too dark.
-[Prue] Yeah.
-[Paul] Wow, that's tough.
[Prue] It is very overbaked.
Absolutely solid. It's like cardboard.
-It's got ground almonds--
-[Prue] It's got too much icing.
-[Prue] Right.
-[Paul] Colour looks nice.
[Prue] It's very shallow,
and they should have risen more than that.
I imagine that's because
there are ground almonds in there.
-It's a nice almond flavour.
-There is a tartness from the jam.
[Prue] It's good.
-[Paul] These are minute.
-[Prue] This is too pink and clumsy.
The flavours aren't too bad.
-Doesn't look great either.
-The ground almonds really pushed it down.
-These are quite high.
-[Paul] Colour's not bad.
[Prue] They're more or less the same.
Just look a bit clumsy.
[Paul] It's the piping.
Cherry. Might be in the fondant.
-Moving on to this.
-[Prue] There's much too much icing.
[Paul] Yes, and that sponge is not good.
Very dry.
I like the flavour. I don't mind it.
-[Paul] What?
-[laughter]
This is the mama one
and this is the baba one.
What's going on? Hang on.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
-Where's the other one?
-Got a confession. [laughs]
[laughter]
[Paul] No almond in the buttercream.
-Is there honey?
-Could be a sweetener, yeah. Okay.
[Alison] Prue and Paul will now
rank the bakers from worst to first.
In 12th place… this one here.
Tom. Overbaked,
they're too dark, and I won't go on,
but they're not very good.
That's fair enough.
In 11th spot, we have Pui Man.
Why did you decide to put
a completely different flavour in there?
-I don't know.
-And in tenth, we have this one.
Hassan. They're a bit pale, messy.
-[Paul] Terrible.
-[laughter]
[Noel] Jasmine is ninth,
Iain's eighth, Nadia's seventh,
Leighton sixth, Lesley fifth,
and Aaron fourth.
In third spot, we have this one.
Nataliia, these weren't bad.
The actual colouring and the neatness
was the thing that we liked.
In the second place… we have this one.
Jessika. You look astonished.
-I am.
-Well, they're pretty neat.
They're nicely risen.
They tasted good. Good job.
-Thanks.
-Which leaves number one…
[all cheering]
No, no, no, no, no. No, no, no, no.
-[laughter]
-Don't clap.
You did have ground almond,
but you managed to get the overall look.
The colour was right.
The decoration was good, so well done.
[all cheering]
I am so relieved.
I feel like I had a little bit to prove
after this morning.
I'm absolutely buzzing.
I'm almost vibrating. [chuckles]
God, it's brutal, isn't it?
That is the roller coaster of Bake Off.
Everything just went wrong from the off.
[Hassan] I'm quite nervous, yeah.
Not very good on the Technical
and not very good on the Signature,
so it's not looking good.
[bleating]
[Alison] The bakers have
just one more challenge
before someone is named Star Baker,
and someone must leave the tent.
We're back.
This is exciting, first Cake Corner.
We've got a lovely set of bakers.
And I love the fact
that we set a really difficult Technical.
[Alison] Toby did the best.
Even you wasn't impressed with that.
They gave a round of applause to him
and you went, "No, no, no, no."
-No, no, no, no.
-[Alison] Calm down.
And when you look at how he did
in the Signature, it was pretty poor.
But the other side of the coin,
I thought Tom, for instance,
did an amazing job with the tartan,
but then last in the Technical.
Yeah, how did that happen?
-[Prue] Jessika.
-[Paul] Jessika again, a real talent.
-[Alison] I agree.
-She's really artistic.
-She is.
-[Prue] What about Nataliia?
Signature-wise, she did well,
and then did well in the Technical.
I'm hoping that Hassan
has a better day today.
-[Noel] I love Hassan.
-[Prue] He's a lovely guy,
but he did have the most
disastrous Signature.
-And Leighton.
-[Paul] Yeah.
He's in a bit of danger
coming into the Showstopper.
So today is really gonna matter.
I'm really excited. It's good to be back.
I've missed you guys.
What do you mean? We all live together.
[all laughing]
[sighs]
[tense music playing]
Oh, welcome back to the tent, bakers,
for your Showstopper challenge.
Today, Paul and Prue
would love you to make
an exquisite landscape cake.
[Noel] No cheating.
You can't pick a landscape
that's already a cake.
Eccles, Dundee, Pontefract.
I mean, they're all lovely places,
but we need you to think outside the box.
You've got four hours
to take us on a journey.
-On your marks.
-Get set.
[in sing-song voice] Bake.
[uplifting music playing]
[Prue] These poor bakers,
for their very first
Showstopper challenge,
are being asked to make a landscape cake.
[Pui Man] Scary.
[mouthing]
I need to dance.
Taste and texture
is obviously critical in this.
What's important is the choice of sponge.
I always say I love a tender sponge,
but the truth is,
that's not the right kind of sponge
for building.
It would just get squashed.
You're thinking on multi levels with this.
You're thinking design.
The flavour combinations,
and then structural integrity.
Ah!
It's quite a warm day today.
[Prue] If anything
is the slightest bit warm,
not only will the icing melt on it
or the filling run,
the cake itself will collapse.
I want to see beautiful landscapes
that taste great.
-[Paul] Morning.
-[Leighton] Good morning.
Good morning, Leighton.
So tell us all about your landscape.
So I'm doing my hometown of Swansea.
-The Mumbles.
-I'm taking you to the Mumbles.
-[Paul] Oh, are you?
-So I'm gonna do the Mumbles lighthouse.
Oystermouth Castle, the Brecon Beacons
just behind with all the daffodils there.
I'm getting really worried now
'cause you're really building this up.
[laughs]
[Noel] Leighton's ode
to the green, green grass of home
will be built
from his favourite cake growing up.
On a Sunday,
my mother baked a Victoria sandwich.
[Paul] Oh, right, okay.
So to take us back to my hometown,
I'm gonna do the Mumbles.
-And a Victoria sandwich.
-[Leighton] And a Victoria sandwich.
[Alison] While Leighton opts
for an all-time classic…
This will be my blackberry
and pistachio cake.
…Jasmine's taking the road less travelled.
Once I've got this in the oven,
I'm gonna make a cardamom cake.
Cardamom has got a pretty strong flavour.
You've got to be careful.
You don't want it to end up
tasting of, I don't know, soap.
[Alison] The unique flavours
in Jasmine's three-tier landscape cake
are a nod to her holidays berry-picking
in the Scottish Highlands,
and her best friend's favourite ice cream.
-I like that colour.
-The pistachio's for Daisy.
She got me on the show.
She pretty much said,
"If you don't do it, I'm gonna…"
-[Noel] I'm gonna enter you.
-Yeah.
-Were you quite nervous of doing it?
-I didn't think I was competent.
-[Noel] Good enough.
-Yeah.
-Now you've seen the other bakers…
-And I'm like, I'm definitely not.
[both laugh]
-Daisy!
-Daisy, what have you done?
What did you do that for?
[Alison] While Paul and Prue will expect
beautifully soft sponges…
[Leighton] It's a bit more solid
than I'd want it to be.
[Noel] …it's crucial they're robust enough
for the bakers to build their landscapes.
[Iain] This is a chocolate stout cake.
I'm using stout
because it's my favourite drink
and it really does add a lot
to the complexity of the chocolate cake.
But this cake is so moist,
stability is a fairly big concern of mine.
[Noel] Iain will carve
his rich chocolate and stout sponge
to build his local beauty spot,
Downhill Beach.
It's one of my favourite places
in the world.
Last summer, I got sunburned
for the first time on a beach in Ireland,
so it holds a very special place
in my heart.
[Alison] Iain's not the only baker
risking a moist sponge.
I'm using quite special apples.
I lived with this wonderful lady
called Betty.
She was in her 90's.
She had this apple tree.
She knew I was applying for Bake Off
and wanted to see me in it.
But I never made it when she was alive,
so I preserved some of her apples.
[Alison] Betty's apples will be added
to a sticky toffee sauce
and drizzled over Jessika's
spiced apple sponge
to form Lake Bunyoni in Uganda,
where she spent
a very special birthday morning.
I basically stayed in a hammock
and then woke up
to the most beautiful sunrise.
I love the idea of the toffee apple.
It's quite autumnal, actually.
You get some really rich flavours.
So I'm looking forward to this.
-[Prue] Good luck
-[Noel] For Betty, right?
[Jessika] For Betty.
So this is pumpkin purée.
It smells horrible but it tastes amazing.
[Noel] Hassan's also hoping to wow
with winter warming flavours.
There's pumpkin spice mix, cinnamon,
nutmeg, ginger, cloves
and a little bit of allspice.
[Noel] Hassan's spiced pumpkin sponge
will form the base of the bamboo forest
he visited in Japan,
a landscape he's hoping
will put him back on the path to success.
Have you practised it?
Yes… ish.
You struggled a little bit yesterday.
This one has to be spot on.
[Toby] Going in.
[Alison] The sheer scale of today's
Showstopper challenge…
-[Jessika] I'm making six tiers.
-…means managing their ovens…
-[Iain] All right.
-…will test the bakers to their limit.
[timer beeping]
Start.
[Noel] As the first sponges hit the heat…
It's done! [laughs]
-…there's no time to rest…
-Now I need to start on the second batch.
…with more cake to make
and fillings to begin.
Welsh jam. It's made with love.
Extra coffee liqueur.
Make them drunk. [laughs]
[Noel] Pui Man's boozy buttercream
will fill layers of coffee
and walnut sponge
stacked to form
Hong Kong's Lion Rock Mountain.
When I was a child,
I used to take the bus to go to school.
[Alison] Yeah?
Lion Rock got a tunnel.
Every time when the bus gets full,
then it's like halfway through.
So when you're in the tunnel,
you know you're nearly home.
Yes.
[Alison] Tom's reliving
a happy childhood, too.
[Tom] I was super lucky growing up.
My Danish granny had a farm in Iceland,
and it is just
the most stunning country ever.
[Alison] He'll recreate the wild landscape
he spent many happy summers exploring
from layers of chocolate chiffon sponge,
white chocolate and hazelnut ganache
and a decadent dark chocolate
and orange ganache.
I want it to be like dark chocolate,
and then the orange comes through.
I don't want it to be, "That should be
coloured orange, that's so orange."
[Noel] While Tom plans to construct
a small section of Icelandic tundra…
If you were to take a slice out of Iceland
and lift it up,
this is what it should look like.
…Nataliia is thinking a bit bigger.
I'm going to make a landscape of Ukraine.
-The whole of--
-The whole landscape?
-How big is this going to be?
-Actual size.
[laughter]
[Noel] From its golden fields
and winding rivers
to the majestic mountains,
Nataliia will build her beloved homeland
from rich chocolate
and rum sponge and cherry jam.
This cake means a lot for me,
especially nowadays.
I've got friends and my family in Ukraine,
so sometimes I got homesick.
I lived a few years in Kyiv.
It's such a wonderful city.
It's full of art,
full of wonderful people.
So, yeah, it's so sad.
[in sing-song voice] Bum, bum, bum!
Ladies and gentlemen,
you are halfway through.
[Noel] Ooh!
[Tom] Three, two, one.
[Alison] As the first of the sponges
exit the oven…
Whoo!
My glasses are steamed,
so give me two minutes.
It's done!
…the race is on to cool them
before assembly can begin.
I know she's behind me.
-[Alison] Those look lovely.
-Thanks.
-Is it chocolate?
-Chocolate stout.
-Oh, stop it.
-Yeah.
If you want a wee drink,
it's still over there.
-Go on, then.
-Oh, I thought you meant the stout.
-I thought you meant the cake!
-[both laugh]
They need a little bit longer.
[Noel] Every minute more in the oven…
I'm just gonna double check these
because I'm terrified.
…is one less they'll have to cool…
-Needs a bit longer.
-…and construct.
I'm gonna add five minutes on.
It's a little bit worrying
because I don't know
if I've exactly nailed this in the time,
in practice.
[Alison] Toby will stack
white chocolate sponge,
brown butter sponge praline
and strawberry jam
to form the famous Jacob's Ladder
staircase of hometown Sidmouth.
And there'll also be a jelly sea,
which is the bit I'm most concerned about
because that has redecorated
the inside of my fridge a few times.
-So…
-[laughter]
[Noel] While Toby celebrates
the good old British seaside…
Second sponge out.
Hopefully, it's cooked this time.
[Nadia] That's coconut liqueur.
…Nadia is taking us
somewhere a little warmer.
[Nadia] My landscape
is a tropical island in Mauritius,
where I went on holiday with my family
and we ate loads of coconut there
and drank loads of mojitos.
[Noel laughs] Wow, what a holiday!
[Alison] Packed full of tropical flavour,
she'll spread lime curd
between layers of coconut and lime sponge
soaked in coconut liqueur.
-Isn't it lucky we like coconut?
-Yeah, isn't it?
I think it sounds lovely.
[Nadia] Well, they like coconut,
so that's a good thing.
'Cause there's a lot of coconut
going in this cake.
[Aaron] This is coconut concentrate
for my buttercream.
Coconut isn't usually that strong,
so I'm hoping it gives it
an extra boost of flavour.
The cake is inspired by a place
in Barcelona that I like, Parc Ciutadella.
[Noel] Complete with chocolate stonework
and a jelly lake,
Aaron's ambitious park
will be built with coconut sponge
filled with coconut buttercream
and miso caramel.
I've definitely got a lot on.
Whether it's too much, I'm not sure,
but go big or go home.
So I just need to assemble my top layer
'cause that's a little bit behind.
[Iain] This is probably
the most important part.
If this doesn't go 100%,
then the stability just isn't there.
[Alison] As the bakers
stack soft sponge and fillings…
[Nataliia] Cherry jam.
…the biggest threat they face is heat.
[Lesley] It's really important
they're cold or the fillings will melt.
You don't want that sloppy mess.
[Noel] Is it quite stressful?
I feel like everyone's
slightly freaking out.
My motto is to go faster.
That looks pretty flat to me.
I'm going to cut now.
I'm starting to cut out the cliff.
[exhales]
[Nataliia] This is the border
with Belarus.
I've got a picture of Ukraine,
like in school, yeah?
[Iain] Oh, God.
[grunts in frustration]
It's just fallen apart.
[gasps]
[exhales]
Oh, man.
That is so horrible.
[sombre music playing]
-[Alison] Just 60 minutes remain…
-[Iain sighs]
…and Iain's Downhill Beach
faces an uphill struggle.
-[Noel] Is it fixable?
-Maybe. We'll see.
I'm on a wing and a prayer right now.
You can do this. Use the Force.
[Iain] I'm gonna try and wrap it
in acetate.
I'm gonna chuck it in the fridge
and just hope for the best.
-It's all right. You've got this.
-I've got this.
You've got it.
[Noel] For the rest of the bakers…
[vocalises]
…construction's in full swing.
[Alison] Are you a good plasterer?
Bet you are.
[exclaims] I've never tried.
-[Noel] As they add the details…
-[Alison] Is that the little road?
…that will bring their landscapes to life.
[Alison] How's it going, Hassan?
All right, I think. I'm rushed for time.
[Jasmine] I'm piping a tree,
which is great with a shaky hand.
[exhales]
[Lesley] I've put some vanilla buttercream
to create a log effect.
I'm making it in the form of a tree stump.
My dad was a carpenter.
We used to go to Wales as kids.
My dad made a camper van,
and we used to go on holidays
in the camper van.
[Alison] Lesley will build her tree stump
from kirsch-soaked chocolate sponge
and cherry jam,
and she'll paint a buttercream
Welsh mountain landscape
in the style
of her dad's favourite artist.
[Lesley] We used to watch Bob Ross.
The voice was so soothing
and Dad had dementia,
so it really calmed him down.
We was watching the Bake Off one night,
and my dad's like, "Have you applied?"
I said, "No." Daddy goes, "Do it! Do it!"
I was like, "Okay, then."
So here we are.
I think he'd be proud. He'd be very proud.
Ladies and gentlemen,
you have half an hour left.
-[Tom] Really?
-Whoo!
-Oh, my God.
-[exhales]
I'm stressed. I am a bit behind.
I wanted to have my chocolate work
done before now.
Running out of time, running out of icing.
This is going to come down to the wire.
It's the Crimean Mountains.
It's looking like home.
[Pui Man] Make it look like lion.
Look terrible.
The cake's in the fridge.
It seems to have gotten a good bit firmer.
I'm just doing my moss now.
[Toby] Now it's all about the sea.
This could go very wrong. Might not set.
This doesn't look like baking to me.
This is science.
[Nadia] This is the agar-agar to set it,
so I do add a lot.
I'll just fix this acetate,
dump it all straight in and pray.
The stress!
I don't even want to breathe.
[Iain] I just need the cake hard.
If I open this
and the cake completely collapses,
that's me gone.
Oh, this is so to the wire again.
I'll take it. Now I'm running.
-Bakers, you've got 15 minutes left.
-Is that all?
Just hammering this as fast as we can.
[Pui Man] Ah! I'm making
a wall of the tunnel.
I measured by eye. Oh, too big. [laughs]
[exhales]
[Leighton] This is the castle,
that's the dragon.
My forest. So beautiful.
That looks absolutely amazing.
[Leighton] Now what we're gonna do
is put the cake on top.
[Jasmine] It's super important
these are lined up.
-[Leighton] Where's the front?
-How do you know?
It's on a bit of a lean, anyway.
Only a little bit.
It looks really precarious.
[sighs, exhales]
[exhales]
-What's that wobble?
-[Alison] Like Leaning Tower of Pisa.
[Noel] Leaning Tower of Mumbles.
[Leighton] Stop it.
[Nadia] We are set.
[tense music playing]
[Hassan] I need to get my trees sorted.
My river. Carefully.
[Lesley] Trying to channel
my inner Bob Ross.
[Iain] That river now
needs to go straight in. Ooh.
I'm making sheep.
[Pui Man] A big, wonky tunnel.
[Leighton] The trouble is my sheep
look like they've got myxomatosis.
I've put my heart where is Kyiv.
[Aaron] I'm just gonna try and cover
as much of the buttercream as possible.
I have to put the wee train on. The cars.
It's gonna be down to the wire.
Bakers, you've got one minute left.
[Toby exhaling] I have got no choice
but to get it off.
[Nataliia] Finishing touches.
Ukrainian flag flowers.
[Jasmine] Putting the last
few toadstools on.
[dramatic music playing]
[Nadia] Toasted coconuts.
[Toby] Oh, it's really soft. Ooh.
Just making some little coconuts
for my tree.
[Hassan] There's more I wanted to do,
but didn't have enough time.
-[Nadia] Give me some to do on the back.
-[Toby] Oh, no! The sea's detached.
Thank you, darling.
Bakers, your time is up.
-[Toby groans]
-Please step away from your Showstoppers.
-[exhales]
-[Alison] Well done, bakers.
-You did it.
-[Hassan exhales]
What a mess.
So upsetting.
[Jasmine] That's actually miraculous.
-[Iain laughing]
-That's insane.
Iain, you've smashed that.
[Alison] It's time to judge
the showstopping landscape cakes.
Iain, would you like to bring up
your Showstopper?
[Iain exhaling]
[gentle suspenseful music playing]
[Paul] That's incredible.
It looks amazing,
and it's so imaginative and crazy.
I love it. Right.
[Iain] This is a chocolate stout,
blackberry jam and cream cheese cake.
[Paul] There's a lot of icing on there.
It's too much.
When you get the fruit and the stout cake,
it works beautifully well together.
I'd happily eat a plateful of that.
Mm. Tastes great. Well done.
-Thank you, Iain.
-Thank you so much.
[mouthing] Well done.
[exhales]
I'm going to cry.
[uplifting music playing]
-[Paul] I think it looks amazing.
-It says tropical.
Just wondering how I'm gonna cut this.
-The back, so swizzle.
-Sorry?
I don't know if that's a word. Swivel.
Have you just told me to swivel?
[all laughing]
[Nadia] I have done coconut and lime cake
with coconut liqueur,
toasted coconut buttercream and lime curd.
[Prue] Love the flavour.
But your cake is overbaked…
-Okay.
-…and that sea is quite tough.
I've put quite a bit of agar in it
because I had to set it. [laughs]
[Paul] Got the texture of a tennis ball.
[laughter]
[gentle music playing]
-[Paul] Happy with it?
-Erm, I had some severe timing issues.
[Prue] It's a little unfinished-looking.
The cake is toasted coconut,
Swiss meringue buttercream
flavoured with vanilla, and miso caramel.
It's certainly coconutty.
You've got a lot of coconut in there.
You need a lime, you need a citrus
to balance out the sweetness.
[whimsical music playing]
[Paul] I think it looks amazing.
-Oh, thank you.
-I love the design.
[Prue] It's beautifully painted.
But let's see what it tastes like,
shall we?
[Lesley] You've got a Black Forest cake,
the sponges have kirsch syrup,
and there's a Black Forest buttercream
and a cherry jam.
-Mm. That is delicious.
-Is it?
The flavours are spot on.
[Prue] And it's beautifully baked.
[Paul] I think you've done an amazing job.
Thank you.
[Noel] You can breathe now.
[suspenseful music playing]
Where's the lion?
-Is this the lion?
-[Pui Man] Yes.
[Paul] I think you could've done
a little bit more on that.
It's coffee and walnut cake
with coffee liqueur buttercream.
-[Prue] I love coffee and walnut cake.
-Oh, good.
[Prue] It's not the lightest of cakes…
-No.
-…but it is very delicious.
[Paul] I do like it. I think the liqueur's
probably a little bit too much.
Little bit too punchy for me.
[dramatic music playing]
It's representational of the Highlands,
but we would've liked to have seen
more landscape rather than three tiers.
But I think it scores
on neatness and style. Beautifully done.
[Jasmine] It is a blackberry
and pistachio cake
with a blackberry and pistachio mousse
in the middle
and the mousse is surrounded
by a cardamom cake.
[Paul] Cardamom level is perfect.
[Prue] Pistachio's perfect too.
-I've never had that combination before.
-No.
That's gorgeous.
[suspenseful music playing]
[Prue] Well… [clears throat]
[Alison laughing]
-It's a bit wobbly.
-[Leighton] Yes.
It's on the lean,
so let's hope the cake tastes good.
It's a traditional Victoria sponge
with buttercream and a raspberry jam.
[Prue] This is a very tough cake.
-Oh.
-[Paul] It is overbaked,
and you can see that the weight
has concertinaed up the bottom.
-I dread to think what's underneath that.
-It'd be delicious.
-[laughing]
-I do like the flavour.
It's a bit simple,
but it is unfortunately overbaked.
[dramatic music playing]
[Prue] It's so beautifully done.
Thank you so much.
The lakes, the rivers,
the mountain ranges, it's just beautiful.
Where's Kyiv?
-There where the heart…
-[Prue] Where the heart is.
-That's where we should have the heart.
-Yeah. I think so.
It's chocolate sponges and whipped cream
with cream cheese and cherry filling.
Stunning.
Thank you so much. [squeals]
The chocolate cake is so intense,
but it's not heavy.
It just imparts flavour,
chocolate, chocolate, chocolate.
It's very delicious.
Yeah, that's a special cake there.
I'm so happy.
-Thank you so much.
-[Paul] Thank you.
[suspenseful music playing]
These bamboo plants seem to be
just chunks of bamboo and no…
Yeah. Er, timing issues.
[Paul] It's odd. It's like a dream.
-[laughter]
-Good dream or bad?
It's a pretty bad one, to be honest.
[laughter]
Let's have a look inside.
My flavour's pumpkin spiced
pumpkin sponge cake
with a pecan praline
Swiss meringue buttercream.
-I love the cake.
-Mmm.
-Beautifully baked.
-[Prue] Beautifully spiced.
But the cream's not carrying much flavour.
Okay.
[gentle music playing]
-[Paul] What happened?
-Time.
Time got the better of me.
And then the sea decided to depart.
[Paul] It's a bit simplistic.
-Yeah.
-[Paul] It's one cake on top of another.
[Prue] Let's have a taste.
[Toby] It has a white chocolate sponge,
a brown butter sponge,
white chocolate buttercream praline,
and strawberry jam.
-I do like the flavours of both.
-[Prue] Hmm, so do I.
But you've slightly overbaked them.
It's a shame.
[suspenseful music playing]
The overall effect is good.
I do like what you've done.
You've kept it quite natural.
-This is your little hammock?
-[Paul] That's a huge hammock.
-I'm not a small girl, Paul.
-[laughter]
It's made up of a spiced apple sponge,
toffee apple and the mascarpone filling.
That toffee apple cake is stunning.
-[exhales]
-[Paul] Mmm.
It's a very challenging cake to make
because you often get them quite claggy,
but that is baked beautifully
and it tastes amazing.
[Prue] It's really delicious.
Well done, Jessika.
[laughs]
Yeah, baby.
Tom, would you like to bring down
your Showstopper, please?
[suspenseful music playing]
[Noel] Wow.
Well, it's beautifully done.
[Paul] Clean, sharp, looks great.
So, now it's gotta taste good.
It's made up of a chocolate sponge,
dark chocolate and orange whipped ganache
and a white chocolate ganache
with hazelnuts.
[Prue] Beautiful layers.
Oh God, it's gorgeous.
[Paul] The orange in it is delicious.
[Prue] It's beautifully baked,
it's beautifully executed.
It's very, what I'm beginning to realise,
is very Tom.
-[Prue laughing]
-You're a good baker, Tom.
You should be really proud of yourself.
-[Paul] Well done.
-Thank you so much.
[Noel softly] Well done, Tom.
[exhales]
Oh.
Do you know what?
After yesterday's Technical,
it's a total relief and, yeah,
honestly, I don't really know yet,
but I'm still in a slight daze from it.
[Toby] That could've gone a lot better.
I really am just holding on to hope
the Technical will carry me through.
[Hassan] Positive and negatives,
so I'm fifty-fifty
on if it'll be enough to keep me in.
[Leighton] I'm very clear
it's gonna be me.
You drop your game slightly
on a Victoria sponge
and it's game over, right?
[Noel] I thought
that was an impressive Showstopper.
I absolutely loved it.
-Such good baking.
-[Alison] Yeah.
I got a bit emotional on Nataliia's bake
if I'm honest.
-[Noel] I did.
-[Prue] It was touching.
The flavour and the texture
she managed to achieve
in that chocolate cake was stunning.
Jessika's cake was amazing.
Tom's cake was exceptional.
And I know he was last in Technical,
but you have to put him in line
for Star Baker because it was that good.
So who's in danger to go home?
-Hassan.
-[Paul] And Toby.
He obviously struggled with time.
It was unfinished.
And Leighton, when we said a landscape,
we meant it to look like a landscape.
Like a landscape, not cakes.
I didn't realise that's what you meant.
-I just thought you meant not portrait.
-[laughs]
You spend too much time on social media.
[laughing]
[suspenseful music playing]
[Noel] Well done, bakers.
Fortunately, I've got the great job
of announcing the first Star Baker
of the series.
The Star Baker is…
[suspenseful music playing]
Nataliia.
-No.
-[all clapping]
Thank you.
Now, unfortunately,
I've got the job that no one wants.
We're just getting to know ya,
but unfortunately,
someone does have to go,
and that person is…
[suspenseful music playing]
Hassan.
So sorry.
Yeah.
-Oh, buddy, I'm so sorry.
-Yeah.
[Tom] Oh, give me a hug. Sorry, buddy.
[Hassan] Yeah.
I think I'm a bit upset.
I did expect it, though.
[Paul] It wasn't your couple of days,
was it, really?
[Hassan] No, no.
Everyone's a really,
really phenomenal baker.
They're all such lovely people.
And even though it's been
a short-lived experience, I've enjoyed it.
Hopefully, I can reflect on some things
and then maybe get back to baking
when I get a chance.
[Tom] I've never appreciated,
watching the show,
how close you get so quickly.
Literally, in 48 hours
of being with these people,
you feel like you know everyone so well.
It's gutting for anyone to go,
but Hassan especially.
He's such a lovely guy.
-[Noel] Well done.
-[screaming]
-We did it. [chuckles]
-[Noel] Well done.
Ta-da!
[Paul] You should feel very proud
of yourself.
Thank you so much.
Star Baker!
I'm in shock, absolutely in shock.
-[Jessika] Well done. Well deserved.
-Thank you.
This cake means a lot for me,
and I so proud.
-[Leighton] Well done, you.
-Group hug. Group hug.
So, yeah, absolutely happy.
Well, you scraped in.
-[Leighton] Oh, God.
-[all laughing]
I was very lucky.
Skin of my teeth, I know.
I live to see another day. [sighs]
Thank goodness for that.
[Nataliia] Can I call my husband?
[line ringing]
-[Harry] Hello?
-I won Star Baker.
[Harry] Really? Wow. Well done. Blimey.
Ah!
[in Ukrainian]
I'm in shock, so much in shock.
[Harry in English] Well done.
That's amazing.
Whoo. [chuckling softly]
Oh, my gosh.
So, yeah, it's a… wonderful day.
[closing theme music playing]